you're slub you lose
YouTube's favorite show everybody no
more you Indians you wish
you're India you win but you slob you
loose you know why cuz at least love can
take a joke why is he walking like that
because he's drunk
come on booty buddy like everyone in
Russia alcoholism it's a problem you
know I actually met a lot of fans who
come up to me and be like I'm slab you
know I loose my it's okay it's just a
joke don't worry about it it's just a
joke remember to buy the mergers look up
yet let us jump into it I'm excited it's
been a long time this is from a normal
day in Russia why is he just standing
there oh
many questions I have many questions
first off why is that horse carriage
connected to a car second off why is
that man standing in the road
third of all how did this happen this is
poorly programmed PlayStation 1 game
right
it's not just Indian that has a deeper
profound skill of expressing their
emotions and love Russians also have a
very romantic way to get it on Christina
give me [ __ ] this really warms my
heart I must say a normal day in Russia
everyone don't be sad bro in other
countries they'll have a dog as a friend
but why have a dog when you can have a
bear you'll never be depressed again oh
this is so sweet
you slap you win
just another day in Russia what is
happening
thinly Russians
there's no groceries there uh smh okay
well Furillo that's actual sexual
harassment moving on you in your slab
you lose everyone a normal lovely bike
ride
wow that's nice let's use okay you three
you might be little do it
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna have to
ask for an explanation and what the heck
was going on there did he grade that
girl's test by drilling it with a drill
why did he what happened
zero to zero ten what four people
dressed as a bus in an attempt to cross
vehicle only bridge just another day in
Russia this just another day Russia
that's all isn't it really cute Hey
Russian cats everybody said real are
they actually squatting
the Slavs have taken feline form very
nice I just dressed those cats up in
adidas and you're good to go
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my teeth
he's gonna hurt someone
oh my god
turn off the thing please you're gonna
cut somewhat
[Music]
of my cup
he got it he got the bishops just a
normal day in Russia everyone oh Jesus
Christ
oh my god
just a normal day in Russia every first
look at that guy oh my god jeez Jess
and it's a whamon is anyone surprised
there was a joke and you wouldn't
remember the cone never forget it
get ready Dmitri a trait that's
innovation right there that takes skill
and cunning this whatever that means
[Music]
okay how are they laughing your kitchen
is on fire
Jesus Christ I do
goddamn beets goddamn cursed Footwear
h-hey my favorite bread Judith what are
those just rocking those aids man what
can I say dude I thought it's the latest
aids goddamn they look sick they look
fire Russian gamer chair improvise adapt
overcome but can it do this I don't I
don't think so Russia's try again this
is why you need to pay 399 but yea quiet
Luka how did this happen
how do you get in this situation
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god okay
everyone made it safe everyone made it
out safe okay all right great
Jesus Christ how is anyone in life
Russians are you okay they replace a
wheel with a log improvise adapt
overcome
hey look it's another log replacement
you know what as dangerous and
life-threatening it seems to be at least
they're having fun you know chase just a
big multiplayer kick with crazy mugs I
saw lots of cars but not the same number
of wheels
the old car is tilting can't tell if
this is sad or hilarious you know I got
somebody in conflicting emotions while
watching this hey hey
they have furries in Russia I didn't
know who would have thought you lost
some cloud today Russia I'm sorry
[Music]
just stop stop using a stop ha Lisa
Jesus Christ with this rocker motivo
dattaji what idiot is cuz I was gonna
say Sweden a lot of times we joke that
to foreigners that we just have polar
bears everywhere and we ride them to
work but in Russia it seems like that's
actually the case
see my fixator video for stylishness
stole nothing wise wait what's that
vodka oh it's vodka Jesus Christ
Russia stop trying to hide vodka and
everything it's a fire
quick let's put it out by pouring
alcohol on it fantastic where all the
wheels in this country where are all the
wheel oh my god oh god it's oh yeah I've
seen the pressed pigeon this is so sad
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
another game rush everyone your slob you
loose whatever it was I hope you had fun
if you did smash like it would have
bought a channel I ran much appreciate
it it helps me a lot as well to push
through to so I can watch more funny
videos for you guys I know it's tough
work goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]